here in brazil everything is okay were
you preparing for the
military to intervene we are not a
military government
brazil is in the news these days for all
the wrong reasons
allegations of high-level corruption
uncontrolled illegal logging
and fires raging in the amazon
rainforest
added to that the third highest figure
in the world
for covid19 infections my guest this
week from brasilia is the country's vice
president
hamilton morale how did the government
let it all get so bad
vice president hamilton morale welcome
to conflict zone
a few months ago you told journalists
everything's
under control we just don't know whose
just how bad is the chaos in your
administration
now everything is okay in our
administration there was a kind of a
joke that i used to say
okay it was not a very
straightforward war that i put it was a
joke
only a joke because here in brazil
everything is okay
what sort of joke was it you had two
health ministers who were gone in the
space of a single month
during a health emergency a justice
minister resigned
an education minister hurries off to the
u.s just days after stepping down from
the job
saying i don't want to fight leave me
alone don't provoke me
isn't that enough chaos for you
no it is not it's not it's things that
happen in any government
okay the the way that the education
minister went out
well it was not a big problem for us
okay
and you know brazil is a very different
country
and well some things that happen here
doesn't happen in other countries
it's our culture so why did you write an
op-ed
may the 14th you said no country in the
world has inflicted
more harm on itself than brazil and you
warned that
institutional damage was driving the
country
into chaos you were the one who
mentioned the chaos and drew attention
to it
you said we become incapable of the
essentials
in facing any problem sitting at the
table talking
and debating that was a powerful
indictment of your own administration
wasn't it because you're
it's leaders like you who are supposed
to unify your country
well the country is suffering what
happens all around the world there is an
uh an excessive of tribalism
and uh political uh the political sides
are
all very let's say polarized
is a lot of polarization in politics
but our administration is running the
country well
and so far as today things are getting
better and the relationship
between the different powers are getting
each day better and better so uh we had
some difficult times some months ago but
now everything's okay
really and added to that the president
his family and several associates are
knee-deep in criminal
and legislative investigations is that
okay too
now this question is still under
investigation
and of course uh it's in the hands of
the judiciary system
and we have to wait for the this process
to get to its end
by warning about all this chaos as you
did last may were you preparing for
the military to intervene and start
dealing with the chaos
in june the president openly floated the
idea of military intervention saying
the armed forces would not accept absurd
decisions by the supreme court of
congress
is that was that a threat
no that's not that's not true first of
all the armed force
are aligned with their constitutional
mission and they are not stepping out of
it
things here in brazil uh are going
smooth and well and it's where we i
gotta make it very clear
that democracy is a value not only for
mr bolsonaro's government but as to our
armed force too
so there is no any any
there is no threat to the the supreme
court or the the justice
system here in brazil and the fact that
he attended rallies
outside military bases where his
supporters called for an
armed intervention to get rid of
governors judges and lawmakers who
imposed lockdowns
in response to the pandemic no threat
there either i suppose
well the question the pandemic people
have to understand that brazil
it's a very an echo country where we're
an equal
socially economic and of course
geographically
so since the beginning of the pandemic
we have been trying to deal
with the health curve with the economic
curve
and with the social curve that's the way
that
mr bolsonaro government dealt with this
pandemic
well he attended rallies which called
for an armed intervention didn't he to
get rid of governors
judges and lawmakers what's that if not
a threat to democracy
you want to play boss is not a threat to
democracy
well the governor of sao paulo thought
it was didn't he
the governor of sao paulo said brazil he
said wakes up every day afraid of
aggression to democracy to the
constitution to the congress to the
supreme court
president bolsonaro he said stop this
endless aggression
now this happens because there is
polarization in politics the government
of sao paulo
uh opposed to mr bolsonaro this is much
more talk than uh
let's say action well it's dangerous it
happens
it stays the way people behave
no it's not dangerous it's dangerous if
you have power to do what you mean
but nobody has the power to do what they
mean with swords here in brazil plenty
of people
seem to think you're doing politics
through fear these days
eduardo costo pinto from the federal
university of rio
he says this is the problem of having a
government filled with military
personnel during an institutional crisis
the military will fight tooth and nail
to stay in power
and they have guns which makes political
mediation difficult
why fill the government with all these
military personnel
if you're not planning on the military
taking over power
first of all it's got to be very clear
that we are not
a military government mr bolsonary and i
were elected by
more than 57 million brazilians okay
and of course we have some people in the
government that come from the military
but they are here sinking for the good
of brazil
and respecting our constitution and our
laws
the federal audit court is now
investigating what it calls the
excessive presence of the military in
civil public service
and it is excessive isn't it the court
said in june there were as many as three
thousand
military personnel in government jobs
what do you need three thousand of the
military in government
jobs for well first of all you have to
be very clear that any government in
brazil
has more than two thousand military in
government jobs
because we have a security cabinet that
belongs to that the president
that has more than a thousand military
people and
in this count of military people are
those who work at the defense ministry
so we don't have such a huge number of
military people occupying
the civil jobs in our government that's
uh some kind
of this information that came through
some
different channels and are all these
military personnel
qualified to do the jobs they're doing
i'm thinking of the
current health minister eduardo pazuelo
he's an active duty general who followed
orders from the president
is that his only qualification he
doesn't know anything about health or
drugs does he
well you don't need to be a doctor to be
the house minister
what you need to be it's a man who
understands the public administration
and more
that you do not uh cope with a
corruption
and of course mr pazuelo laws are not
about logistics that was the main
problem
in our house minister and he knows how
to obey orders more than the other
health ministers does he he knows to do
as he's told
that's his main qualification is it
well he has the qualifications and he
has been doing a very good job
and this has been attested but all the
the secretaries
of the different states here in brazil
they are all very
uh pleased with the job that mr pazuelo
has been doing
because all the necessary support for to
fight
and control the pandemic has reached
every point in the
in our in our country mr vice president
mr bolsonaro has never hidden his
admiration
for brazil's former military
dictatorship
do you share that admiration
well we had a period of uh
military presence that lasted about 20
years
they had they did very good things for
brazil
and other things they didn't go so well
and this is history and
history can only be judged uh when
time pass we are still some
50 years away from that period we need
some more 50 years
so that the spirit can be judged well
well
during the vote to impeach former
president dilma rousseff
mr bolsonaro dedicated his ballot to one
of the regime's
most notorious torturers this man was
convicted
of torture during the 21 years of
military dictatorship
last year your president called him a
national hero
502 cases of torture were identified
in the unit he ran you have nice heroes
in your administration
these days don't you now first of all we
don't
we don't agree with torture tortures is
not
a politics that our country is sympatic
to it
and of course when uh there is a lot of
people that fought
the urban guerrillas during the late
sixth and beginning of the seventh of
last century
and many of these people have been
wrongly accused
of being torturers so colonel carlos
alberto ustra was wrongly accused and
you also think of him as a hero do you
despite the cases the 500 cases of
torture which were attributed to his
unit
what i can tell you about the man carlos
alberto brilliant huster
he was my commanding officer in the late
seventh of
the last century and he was
a man of uh honor and a man who respect
the human rights of
his subordinates so ben of things that
people tell about him
i can tell you because uh i had a very
close friendship with this man
that's not true so he was wrongly
convicted then of torture was he
it was all made up well
the the trial was fixed first of all i'm
not
i'm not aligned with the with torture
and of course
many people are still alive from that
period and all
of them want to put things in the way
that they saw
that's why i told you before that we
have to wait for all these sectors
to disappear so that history can make
its part
and of course what really happened
during that period that period come true
well given that you and your president
are not prepared to
condemn the torturers only torture can
you not understand why so many people in
brazil and internationally
doubt your commitment your
administration's commitment
to democracy can you understand that
well democracy it's one of a nash of our
national
permanent objectives we don't see brazil
out of democracy our main objective
today is make of brazil
the most brilliant democracy in the
southern hemisphere
really and with people like augusto
helleno minister of institutional
security
another retired general he's on record
and saying he believes it's up to the
military
to put this house in order this house
meaning brazil
another threat you have all these people
who are prepared to make threats but you
say
there really isn't a threat i'm confused
mr vice president well like i told
like i've been telling you this makes
parts of the discussion that we have the
polarization in politics
okay it's mostly words then
actions because you won't name one
single action from mr boson our
government
there was a real real real threat to
democracy here in brazil
but words matter in politics don't they
you play it all down but even the
supreme court's chief justice diaz
toffoli warned in june about the
president's
dubiousness about democracy he said
dubiousness that's not a great
characteristic for a democratic
leader is it he's dubious about
democracy
well i think there is no way to think uh
there is some dubious uh
feelings of the mr bolsonaro to
democracy
including last saturday for instance mr
bolsonaro and mr toughly were
eating together in a dinner so if mr
topperfully had any doubt about
the way mr bolsonaro behaved they would
not be together in the hit
in their house in his house back apart
for that
your former justice minister sergio moro
accused the president of interfering in
an investigation into his family
basically attempting to obstruct justice
this is a
highly damaging allegation from a
minister who used to be well liked
and respected by mr bolsonaro wasn't it
well mr muru made these accusations
these are are being investigated
through the the supreme court now we are
waiting for
this investigation to come through okay
and
of course we have to wait for this
process to end
i myself i'm well
i'm side by side with president
bolsonaro during all this time
and i can tell you that he did not
interfere
in the federal police and the work and
the federal police so that he could help
some of his sons that are being accused
of some wrong doings how do you know he
didn't
did he tell you that he didn't know that
well
well i've been with mr bolsonaro since
the
2018 we've been working closely together
and i can tell you he is not interfering
the work
of the federal police the federal police
is doing her job they are investigating
all this case
and that our judiciary system is
investigating the problems that
one of his sons has so i see that this
process is going
as the way all process go here in brazil
mr vice president how important is uh
truth
in your administration let's take the
issue of deforestation
and the fires this year in the amazon
august the 10th
you said government agents were
executing urgent measures to contain
deforestation and fires a day later
president bolsonaro said the exact
opposite
you won't find any spot of fire he said
nor a quarter of a hectare deforested
the report that the amazon is burning is
a lie
in fact it was his statement that was
the lie wasn't it because the amazon was
clearly burning
at that point well they don't deny what
happens
and we've been working very hard
to stop any legal deforestation and
illegal fires that happen in the amazon
what has bee is clear is deforestation
has been increasing
since 2012 accelerated last year
since the the second half of these
months of june last june
uh deforestation has been decreasing so
the work
is beginning to pay now and of course we
still have the problem of the fires
we are in the dry season the dry season
uh
year to year is beginning to be bigger
and bigger
and of course we have to have more
resource we have to put more resource
in the fight again against the
illegalities that happens in the amazon
area
yeah but when mr bolsonaro august the
11th said
the there is no fire the report that the
amazon is burning is a lie that
itself was a lie it wasn't true was it
simply wasn't true so why lie about
these things
what happened no no what happens in the
amazon for the question of fires
well it's very clear we a lot of
we have some more than 500 000 farmers
in the amazon area
and some 5 of them about some 25 000
farmers they work their fields with fire
and that's well that's a very uh ancient
uh uh system to work the field so we
have to make them
stop this so that uh the fires
don't grow year to year the fact is
these are the worst fires
in a decade aren't they in september
your satellites recorded more than 32
000 hot spots in the rainforest 61
rise over the same month last year and
in both september
and august when your tele president was
telling us there were no fires
the blaze matched or surpassed last
year's
single month high so the science
director for your amazon environmental
research institute said
we have had two months with a lot of
fire it's already worse
than last year the satellites can see it
why do you deny it's worse than last
year now we don't deny
we don't deny anything okay september of
this year has been worse since september
last year but like i told you before
some 70 percent of these fires are
raging in the areas that have have been
already deforested
many many many years ago that are
occupied by farmers
only one-third of them are happening in
areas that they wouldn't do should not
happen
and we are fighting then since the
beginning of the
the green brazil two operation that we
launched
since the months of may where we
stopped some six thousand points of fire
so we've been doing our jobs you've been
doing your jobs but um
not very effectively it seems according
to reports on the ground
if the fires are that bad and there are
still 32 000 hot spots
in the rain forest the 61 rise over the
same month last year that's not very
effective is it
well like i told you the season is very
dry
so it's the moment that fire happens and
of course you say 32 000 hot spots 32
000 hot spots
in an area of 5 million square
kilometers
i think you are can agree with me that's
not so huge
our people are telling around the wood
okay
because the amazon is very huge so
what's been passing to all around the
world that the whole amazon is
in fire and that's not happened the
fires happen
like i told you in areas that have been
already
deforested since many many years ago
mr vice president the accusation from
human rights groups is that your
administration has deliberately
undermined efforts by your own federal
agents
to stop deforestation human rights watch
says that while federal authorities
impose
thousands of fines for illegal
deforestation
a presidential decree has allowed most
of them to go
unpaid what's the point of doing that
no we don't uh comply with illegalities
in the amazon right
for instance our uh environmental
legislation say that any property in the
amazon
can explore 20 of its area the other 80
percent
has to be preserved but you let people
get away with not
paying fines you let people get away
without paying fines
why almost everyone gets away with not
paying the fines
well see if people don't pay fines
if they don't pay they fi their fines
the land that they have is going to be
arrested
but so far as today we have a problem of
regulation of the land tenure
we need to regulate this this is a big
problem that we still have in brazil
okay and uh we are dealing with this in
the national council
that i'm the head of the council that's
one of my main objectives
i've been working together with our
agriculture minister
so that we can go ahead with this
because it's very important that we
solve this problem
because only repression against people
who are making things wrong it's not it
will not
end the illegalities we need to advance
with the land and new regulation well
why should these criminal groups
involved in deforestation stop when
when your penalties are taken away and
they're not even
obliged to pay fines means everyone gets
away with it with no penalties which is
exactly what you wanted
and mr bolsonaro made no secret of his
intentions
he openly attacked his own environmental
agencies
which he called industries of fines and
promised to end
their festival of sanctions so he made
it quite clear
that he wanted to take away the
sanctions take away the punishment
and let all the illegal logging go ahead
he was quite clear about that
well mr bolsonary spoke about that when
he was a candidate
and and a candidate you know it speaks
about a lot of things
so it wasn't it wasn't true it wasn't
true
yeah all the reports on the ground say
that's exactly
what he's done we put some 300 million
dollars in fines
that's a lot of money okay so our
environmental agents
they have the freedom to do their job
they are
putting fines on everybody that are
doing illegalities well that's not the
reports coming from the ground
mr vice president uh final word on the
pandemic when it comes to the
coronavirus you have around 4.7 million
confirmed cases
the third highest in the world after the
u.s and india
more cases than all of europe not a
great record is it
well like i told you before
okay brazil has a lot of inequalities
okay we are not an equal country we have
problems in the social and economic
and in geography you know of course we
have a huge geography here in brazil
so we try to fight this the best way
possible we regret
almost 105 000 brazilians that we lost
their lives
but we uh have cured more than four
million people here in brazil
so i think that despite this number of
case and number of deaths
we dealt very good with this pandemic
cries
how much how much use was it for the
president to call it just a measly cold
and say to people
i think almost all of you will catch it
one day what are you afraid of
how about being afraid of dying or
having health long-term health problems
or blood clots
not much he hasn't got much sympathy for
his people has he
yeah of course the preparation is has
been always concerned about the people
the president since the beginning of the
pandemic
said it very clear we have to take care
of the health
and we have to take care of the economy
because we know that a lot of people
here in brazil
they well they have very difficult to
earn their money
because we are not living a period of
economic crisis that we don't have jobs
for everybody
people live in an informal way and from
night to day these people lost
any chance to have some kind of revenue
so the president who knows the common
people
knew that about all right vice president
hamilton morale thank you very much for
being on conflict zone thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you